you should be extremely afraid thank you
for bringing us collectively to this
moment it is a moment but so many have
dreamed of claiming history starts today
[Music]
the guy who is the evil person I don't
work for him my phone works better
are you gonna behave yourself tomorrow I
told you I wanted to my job I'm a
reporter I follow people that do not
want to be followed
what about the allegations that you
recruit the most vulnerable for tests
that end up killing people you tell me
Joe you finish mr. boss is that a threat
you had to learn how to hide in plain
sight I'm pretty good at it for you you
suck
whoever you are I work at the Life
Foundation and I need your help we found
something we call them symbiosis
Carleton Drake believes that the union
between human and symbiote is the key to
our evolution
I'm feeling really sick
I'm hearing boys
you're not real you were just in my head
I'm gonna need mr. Drake's property back
if you're gonna stay you will only hurt
bad people when I see it do whatever we
want do we have a deal
be willing to sacrifice
the one thing you haul most dear
you should be extremely afraid
what the hell are you we
off it
you
you